[Music]
Devil May Cry 5 is arguably the best
game in the franchise so far and it
stands as another knockout hit for
Capcom in 2019 the game sees the return
of Dante & Co as they attempt to take
down a powerful new demon there's a lot
of things to unpack from the ending and
those who've completed the game may
leave it with more questions than
answers so throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the finale of it and what
it teases for the future this is full
spoilers ahead so if you don't want to
know anything about the ending of the
game and I highly suggest that you turn
off now without the way I'm definition
and welcome to the channel where I play
it so you don't have to when playing
through DMC 5 one of the biggest
questions you may have is who is B this
mystery man possesses the ability to
summon demons and his unique fighting
style is one of the coolest things about
the new game throughout the game his
identity is teased and as we progress we
learn that it is actually tied directly
to euros n the game's Big Bad it turns
out that V used to be part of euros n
and this detachment explains why he is
physically weaker than both Nero and
Dante there's also a massive reveal
about eurozone that ties into Dante's
backstory quite heavily this is because
euros n is actually Dante's brother
Virgil who is of course a mainstay
villain of the game series it completely
caught me off guard even though the
virtual clue is in B's name in the early
stages of DMC we see Nero's arm taken by
a mysterious figure a lake it turns out
to be virgil who is looking to gain
power from the underworld with Nero's
arm he was able to use the power of
yamato to stab himself and create v from
this point on eurozone begins to
culminate power and become the main
villain of the piece B who is slowly
losing his lifeforce in the game
eventually makes it to the point where
Dante and eurozone are facing off the
game
each other Dante manages to defeat
eurozone but in doing so allows B to be
reabsorbed into him and this allows
Virgil to become whole again at this
point Nero returns and Dante reveals
that Virgil is in fact his father which
if you haven't seen Star Wars before
it's probably a shocking revelation as
Dante is generally a good guy he doesn't
want Nero to have to kill his own father
so he steps into taking down
Nero doesn't quite want to lose his
father though so he steps in sure that
there's a way to stop virgil without
killing him this allows Nero to unlock
the devil trigger and this creates a new
form that allows him to stop Dante and
Virgil from fighting it's not over yet
though and Virgil and Nero make a deal
like if Nero can be his father then he
will stop the underworld from coming to
the real one those who managed to defeat
Virgil will see Nero Dante and Virgil
realize that the only way to stop the
underworld rising is to seal the portal
the downside of this is that someone
needs to be on the underworld side in
order to close it from the end which
Dante volunteers for Nero tries to step
forward for the role but Dante states
that Nero is more than capable of
protecting the world now which is a big
moment as he's been pretty hard on the
character throughout the game there's a
bit of a twist when Dante and Virgil
both seal the portal from the underworld
and decide to continue their feud there
but this allows the planet to return to
normal back in the normal world
Nero continues to travel with Nico and
they set out to continue their demon
hunter back at Devil May Cry Trish and
lady are hanging out wondering what to
do when Morrison appears and tells them
they has a job which obviously hints at
a sequel I can see this following Dante
and his battle with Virgil in the
underworld as well as the continuation
of Nero's journey obviously we will find
out when the next game in the series
comes out which I can't wait to play of
course I'd love to hear your thoughts on
the game and what you took from its
ending if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of last week's other
big release Captain Marvel which would
be linked at the end this is a channel
for the hardcore players so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you
being the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]